because I wouldn't be able to believe
that this is happening to me facts how
is why is this happening to me bro I
would never click on an Xbox profile so
fast in my life who is he I would assume
the pension squeeze third screenshots
soon
I need to see that profile pic fax wow
[Music]
right guys we are back and as you
already know being the second biggest
podcast in the world we have to go
straight in with the nitty gritty and
the nitty-gritty is the question of the
week obviously and the question of the
week this week was
what lengths did you go to to keep that
Affair a secret oh what where did you
find that did you make that open your
head don't worry about what I get these
questions
that's a buff question it's a buff
question what links did you go to to
keep that fair a secret caveat that that
t-shirt is sexy bro yeah it's on here
yeah that's a buff shirt come on man
fair play the material looks crazy as
well it is all because you know why I
got it as well you know what it was Tick
Tock makes me do everything these days
okay so I bought some anime tops from
Tick Tock like a month ago okay and they
were ass the quality was asked okay and
um
then
literally the next week I saw another
Tick Tock advert for these and they were
like pre the quality and they had the
camera like here and they were just like
stroking through the fibers and I was
like that is good quality
so I ordered them and they came the
other day yeah man this one is he
wearing a astronaut yeah
yeah it's hard it looks very cool I
haven't seen anybody like it I got three
of them this one another what's his name
yeah another youtubero one
um
and uh got a uh
what's his what's his uh teacher chords
uh Gojo Gojo Gojo one but Gojo's in like
a little Gojo Sensei he's like a animoji
type thing like a little cute little
cute thing very buff very very Buffy
anyway guys back to the nitty gritty
what lengths did you go to to keep that
Affair a secret as per usual guys
the responses were Beyond juicy I can
imagine they're impeccable
I can tell you're like you're gagging
for it so it's calm
it's called
all right
I told him I was tutoring
underprivileged kids for free three
times a week I did this for a year
just no no explanation just
underprivileged kids for free tutoring
three times a week for a year for a year
so she could this is a girl guy that was
a girl that said that I I could tell
yeah a guy's never gonna lie like that
that's too much yeah under privileged
kids for three times a week that's too
much of a lie she will know I'm lying
man don't ask enough questions yeah yeah
because I know I wouldn't either I would
just be like sweat I swear you've got I
think you've got energy to waste that
I'm not wasting my time
like Kudos yeah yeah yeah this is why I
love you all them things
that's matter three times a week 52
weeks a year yeah she went every week 52
times three is what 156 good maths good
quick maths I'm brazy with you sometimes
you remember you showed me that in uni
yeah you said something and you know I
was like
a level right yeah yeah
who's actually doing that I've actually
been um I will come back to this but
I've actually been doing a um uh a
mental um game mental training game on
my phone it's called impulse um I got
um intro to actually and I play every
day and it just like tests my my brain
capacity my knowledge my um retention
span everything swear yes it's buff I
haven't played every day it's buff gang
um actually fun yeah yeah there's so
many different games I want it I want it
so many different it's very wonderful
like I could be watching TV and I'll be
on my phone for an hour because I'm
playing again yeah all right say less
okay uh is there a leaderboard can I
compete uh you can but I've not done
that yet but I think you can like share
stats on with iOS and blah blah blah
that's that's what I care about yeah I
know I the other day but yeah gang
um next I made the kids promise to not
talk about mommy's friend to their dad
Jesus Christ because it's one of those
ones with kids kids say the wildest [__]
kids will just say stuff yeah so it's
like
you must have been bribing your you
there's how are you there's enough like
there's nothing my mum could have asked
me that I wouldn't tell my Dad yeah
because you can't say don't tell your
dad about this prayer because I'll get
scared that's all like I'm gonna be
thinking about because if I don't tell
him will I get in trouble if I do tell
him will I get in trouble exactly so I'm
in between a rock and a half place you
can't put me in that situation yeah
don't pin me against my father or your
father don't do that we are one yeah
we're a family we're a family don't do
that yeah wow yeah yeah Mommy's friend
someone took a photo of me kissing
somebody I proceeded to chase them and
break their phone
facts was that guy that said that no I
was like really yeah it's the three
goals so far uh yeah so far disgusting
my baby daddy took down all the pics in
his house of him and his wife when I
came over
baby daddy
ah yeah that's
wait what yeah wait wait yeah wait yeah
wait my baby daddy it just it just
landed my baby daddy took that all the
pics of him and his wife when I came
over when I came over with with said
with you bro when I came to his and his
wife's house he would take down all the
pictures as a courtesy yeah
whilst I'm with the heat
that's not mental that's insane that's
mental it's not an affair anymore
we can't keep this a secret we can't
unless we move yeah yeah
wow
my best friend burnt her neck with
straightness to hide the love bites from
her husband
I did that before yeah as soon as I read
that I said it's giving James it's
giving James
I did that before
I giggled to myself I scratches my shin
I wash it my skin my traps I remember
bro what a love bite on my shoulder I
got my hairbrush and scratched the [__]
on my skin and then I scratched the
other side said I was quite heavy I
remember like it was yesterday bro you
said he was squatting I'm like wow
you're a liar
I've never met anyone like it I remember
that as well Jesus it hurt doing it it's
all it was painful bro just there in the
mirror I was there in the middle of
scrubbing that's hilarious Jesus
teenagers oh yeah naive team cyanail
spam
I would turn off her sleep apnea machine
so she wouldn't have the energy to ask
me questions
that's brutal bro she hasn't slept
that's brutal she's been snoring waking
up snoring and waking up choking on her
tubs I won't she won't have that then
she's asked questions yeah play that's
the length now she's gonna say just go
that's the length he went to wow wow
changed his Snapchat name to team
Snapchat Fair strong Fair strong
gave my ex a laxative so I knew exactly
where she'd be all day
okay okay this is getting bodies are the
lengths these men are gummies it's
getting intense so I know where she'd be
all day on the toilet
so I just know where so I can cheat in
peace in absolute peace she's never
gonna borrow a ringer yeah she's busy
bro no no no no no no tell me what I see
you baby she's busy bro
wow she walked into the mall when I was
with my girl I sprinted to the bathroom
slipped and tore my ACL
yikes
I'll be so angry yeah of course I would
be so angry of course I you know what I
used to do when I was um when I was a
cereal cheap yeah
When I Was a Serial cheat when I was
younger I used to I would be in my car
in
side chicks ends yeah yeah and I'll be
thinking if I crash my car it's long
Johnny if I get injured here it's [__]
yeah what am I gonna do yeah Who you
gonna call and what you're gonna say fam
Who you gonna call insurance companies
want details when they want a police
report yeah where would I and why was I
there
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah Tottenham Court
Road why are you what do you need there
man's in central
what do you need there on a Wednesday
afternoon hilarious he said you were at
the gym
the police report says otherwise I
couldn't I couldn't be facing I used to
have panic attacks about it wow wow yeah
bro facts
I knew her best friend was broke so I
gave her money to back up my lies
oh that's a steep slope that is yeah
because because she she's bending you
over literally I want more money now the
price just went up
stupid mistake
drove to work so my boyfriend would see
my car in the parking lot but my side
would pick me up from around the back
what's going on bro reading this made me
realize or it just cemented that women
cheap like of course they do I know
they're cheaper like they it cemented
the fact that they do it so well oh of
course bro and the thing is the reason
this is this is you know what I'm not
going to give women too much credit here
the reason women do it so well is
because side man are willing to
participate oh to be fair it's a win-win
like literally if home girl's telling me
my boyfriend's gonna drop me out front
make sure you pick me up from the back
oh say less I don't care yeah yeah to be
fair yeah
when but the vice versa girls too many
questions bro there's one I pick you up
from the back front I could never ask a
girl to pick me up from the back first
of all you're not picking me up anyway
yeah
secondly if you are picking up you're
picking me up from the back yeah and if
you're coming you ain't entering through
the back yeah pause yeah enter for the
back either yeah because I can't I can't
tell you that oh it's like there'll be
too many questions she's like I've never
seen you again
that's exactly what she'll say 100. I
quit my full-time job and got two
part-time jobs so I had two excuses to
see the other chick
that's more hassle that it's worth oh
who says to see the other chick
more hassle than it's worth I pretended
to be a lesbian in front of his wife
so that means who are you lips in
I think it could have just been like a
flirt eating it must have been but I I
just don't know what my mental
gymnastics would be looking like if I'm
in the same space with my wife as well
as my side chick and she's pretending to
be lesbian because she can mess this
dance up today and it sounds like you're
trying to pull a scam factual it trines
it sounds like you're trying to out me
extravagant yeah
extravagantly you're doing too much too
much yeah you're trying to out me
extravagantly yeah I'll yank your hair
out the door I would never have my side
in my main together in the same four
walls or what kind of fire are these men
playing with yeah that's that's a
Bravado I never want to reach I
pretended to be a lesbian in front of
his wife also just pretend to not be my
sighting how about that facts just act
like you don't know yeah
yeah like you don't know doing the most
the most Jesus I told her if she called
my girl I will tell the whole office she
[__] like a starfish
she just lays there
also that's a threat I couldn't say to
someone because she's ringing my girl
I'm not saying by the way if you tell my
God I'm going to tell everyone you bang
like a starfish I'm billing the right
yeah right there yeah yeah you're you
don't rape me at all I'm bailing her
immediately it's ringing go on then
draft your email because I'm calling her
now your email draft is yeah casting
that you want to do put it on the slack
Channel I don't care tell everyone
Slack
jokes
wow that's a threat I've never had the
balls to threaten any woman like that no
that's that's because I know they're
gonna double cross off caught a double
cross
wow I've never had the don't you dare in
me yeah that's that's it's just like hey
please listen listen love me Larry babe
listen listen listen you're not thinking
about us long term you know what I mean
think about this properly like actually
deep what you're about to do you can
mess up the whole base yeah yeah it's a
whole base
and it's fun yeah we love this it's
secret it's forbidden that's the best
thing about it so if you Bella this is
never gonna happen again you need to
understand that and you think like
because you're Bella and then me and her
break up but you think I'll come back to
you and I promise you I'm not I'm I
never will because once she's done with
me I'm done with you it's a Continuum
yeah do you know what I mean it's a
domino effect so if you're doing this
out of love or passion or whatever don't
do it you'll never see or hear from me
again again deal wow you're just
sabotaging the whole thing the only
threat I would of ended up I don't know
if it's ever happened to me but I feel
like it might have I would just let them
know my girl will thump you up
she will come here yeah yeah and she'll
put hands on you she'll send for you
first and I'm not gonna do anything I'm
not gonna hit a woman I'm not going to
drag anything away yeah yeah she's gonna
bang you in the face tell my girl at
your own risk facts this is health and
safe because she's not gonna appreciate
this phone call Bro facts I promise you
now she's gonna be more mad at you than
she will be at me facts so I was
cheating in peace and quiet she didn't
know you brought this to her table yeah
so yeah I think your teeth might get
shifted yeah so loud the whole thing
yeah
Rags because now she's got nothing to
lose zero because she's done with it
yeah her man just portrayed her she's
done with me she's getting exposed to a
whole officer for the people oh she's
gonna comfy bang him in the face yeah
don't you dare don't you don't that's
the winner I'm flipping it ain't got
time for all of this oh God
started Uber driving so I had a reason
for my location to be out at our meat
spot
what do you mean
Uber driving
actually now I'm deep in it that's
because you on Uber you can just work
your own hours yeah yeah oh interesting
you can do what you want yeah yeah you
can work around yes you can just sign up
to be an Uber driver and then just go
and cheat yeah and then come back and
then come back and I just did a shift
you just need to make sure you've got
money in your body facts you need to
make sure you've got money coming in she
can never know you've got money coming
in because why are you driving yeah why
Uber driving if you've got peace yeah
that's I couldn't live up with them lies
it's too much it is way too much
actually also because it's like when you
just want to like you said like when
when you want to have a day playing
Harry Potter yes she's like what are you
what are you doing you need to be on
these streets yeah yeah and when you're
just yeah because like eventually you're
going to be bored of cheating yeah I
just want to pay yes you know what I
mean I just want better I want my girl
yeah yeah yeah I'm tired of these
streets someone cheat anymore yeah and
she's like big man we need we need bread
and water like and you're chilling in
here like I don't understand what's
going on you'd have to expose yourself
yeah I was never an even though yeah all
of that was a facade yeah yeah all that
was a facade all of that yeah it might
as well have been fake taxi
[Music]
and I just want you now
good Lord I was doing the most that I
just want you the guilt is eating me
inside out fake taxi yeah that's not my
I could never let those words come out
my mouth and let her hear that I
couldn't I was doing up fake taxi
[Music]
oh my Lord
oh the the neighbors were here yeah yeah
it'll be a fight in the yard
it will be a fight in the other
neighbors would hear it wow she she
would chase me around the yard James
that's mad
that's jokes
right uh what lengths did he go to to
keep that Affair a secret
told him I had Bible study every
Thursday but I was in my sightings work
van getting pumped
every Thursday
wow come on man
I hid in a trunk while he drove into his
garage so the neighbors wouldn't see me
that's effort that is effort but it's
all if I'm whipping and she's like is it
time for me to get and she just knows
the role sexy tantalizes
everywhere sexy
yes and she's like calm you can't let
the neighbors see me coming out I'll get
in the truck as tantalizing seriously
gets out that trunk my dick's already
out yeah my dick's already harder now
because that's the sexiest thing you
could have said to me today
sleep
yeah
hilarious
I flushed my phone down the toilet after
my friends tried to forcefully take it
and read my messages
damn friends yeah so it was probably one
of those ones where she doesn't want
anyone to know about this yeah yeah this
is like her friends are also like
married to her husband's friends
Housewives yeah yeah
it's a judgment is this is not it's not
a judgment-free Zone and that's not a
place I want to be in
um I had my homie Rob her so she ain't
got the receipts no more
there is no way in hell like the maddest
thing about that one is I've set my wife
up yeah yeah I've set her up and I've
told Ram to Rubber and she comes to him
crying one day I just have to play it
off
Bells meal Simon like yo babe what's up
and she's like oh Babe oh she can't even
bail me they took her phone I just did
stand bro done it's not even your wife
it's the side
exciting would have got robbed no to
keep their feds no you said robbed her
so she ain't got the receipts your wife
ain't gonna have the receipts oh yeah
your sightings got the receipts exact
facts facts that's long the whole thing
is long
ah
snapped my phone in half when I showed
him his own news on another girl's
Snapchat
his own nudes
um
it's the most humiliating experience a
man could ever face I was I think I
would ghost for a year
I would delete everything James
thanks bro because I'm not the how is
she seeing this will snap is this on God
knows it's everywhere now I'm the I'm
the part of the joke clearly I'd have to
ghost for a year I'll set up camp
somewhere
D yeah Cornwall yeah yeah off start a
game off and are you that guy nah nah
it's not me bro own news on another
girl's Snapchat news you're embarrassing
that is I could drive in and she's like
babe yuck is it
I can't
be here with you yeah
I have to escape yeah fast I will open
the door roll roll the [__] out yeah
yeah yeah yeah
figure the a13 on your own I promise you
I'll comfortably pack a bag and leave
damn bro I would I would hold my hands
up and be like look I'm a cheat clearly
you've caught me clearly I can't you
know I can't have this yeah yeah yeah I
don't do conferences
yeah yeah to do I'm gonna block you say
what you need to say about me I'm gonna
dip yeah [__] say it now yeah because
you're never speaking to me again yeah
yeah
tell your close friends what they need
to hear
cause I'm out and obviously you can
understand yeah yeah where I'm coming
from not me yeah you know where I'm
coming from she's going to be 10 times
more mad she'll be livid that's like
what am I supposed to sit here and take
it for you to dump me anyway no ow and
if you don't dump me what you can throw
it back in my face every six weeks when
we argue no I'm gone yeah I'm gone
living through that
why oh damn
I made fake timesheets up so you thought
I was working night shifts while I slept
at the other guy's house
what is the incentive for these
excessive lies what's the incentive
probably the affair must have been bath
it must have been unbelievable like I've
never had an affair before
have you seen the show Affair there's a
show called affair on Skype yeah that
was raunch yeah so you see what I'm
saying I feel like there's a level to
the point where I have to make up fake
timesheets where I'm like this is not
sexy it of course it's not when admin
gets involved yeah I want it to be
nonchalant banging an Alia behind a calf
you know I mean we need to sneakily yeah
get these yeah yeah I don't want routine
stuff yeah plans so I can sleep at your
yard like no we're doing a double
relationship yeah and it's not sexy
anymore I want an affair yeah that's why
I want an affection I want fashion
yeah that's all I want I don't want fake
admin stuff
that's jokes Jesus oh
all right I got a couple more
um what lamps did you go to to keep that
secret and affair keep that fair a
secret wow that's my dyslexia kicking in
I asked my friend to try and [__] my
boyfriend so he so I knew he was busy
when I was out
I asked my friend to try and [__] my
boyfriend so I knew he was busy when I
was out that could that's given
trafficking that
bang my man so I can bang next man
bro free up your tongue to my man that's
mad so I know his location so I know
he's busy so I can cheat
what in God's name well yeah I don't
know what's going on with that boy
because that can get sticky because if
if I'm unbeknownst to me my wife is
going out she's being a dog I have no
idea and her Brethren comes to me and be
like yo I've been praying you for a
minute let's do something I'm not
banging I don't care how howling is she
enough for you to have been considering
it before this even came up in
discussion okay do you know what I mean
yeah and like uh her leg is sweeted uh
how sure am I that she's gonna stay
strong that's up to you so it's one of
them ones when you have no idea this
this is a facade you have no idea of
course so you have to double down and be
like if you bang her you'd be like
too late
bro
um no I don't think I could because I'm
thinking this is oh I don't know what
questions I need to ask to make sure
it's not trap yeah true from the first
message I'm thinking trap true you might
think I'm foolish traps second missions
is trapped I don't know at what point
we're getting to yeah unless she's
sending me stuff yeah
then I might not think it's a trap
but I don't know how would even get to
that point factual because it's more
entertaining is my girl's bedroom yeah
yeah I think what I'd have to do is
I'm having to screen record yeah this
whole conversation and keep flicking
over to my notes and be like Sarah I
know this is a trap Sarah I know this is
a [__] trap but I'm gonna entertain
this conversation yeah yeah swipe back
to the convo okay entertain the whole
time okay okay yeah you've got it yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've got receipts got
yourself backed up yeah yeah so when
these men try and trap me on the day
I'm like ah joke's on you boom I knew it
was a trap and then when no when when no
one's hide in the bushes and she's
actually down good Lord come through
good Lord come through let's do
everything you've been talking about
I wanted to find out my girls are doing
the most
yeah see that Uno reverse that because
I'll play victim when I find out all
right goal not only did you cheat on me
and break my heart you swindled me into
bed with a gun I don't care about
I might commit arson that day
because I can't think of any other crime
I might be awesome
it might be awesome
oh that's jokes wow
um the last one
I pretended to be a gay cousin I even
showed up in crop tops and shorts no
how bad must you have to be and crop
tops and shorts and where like who are
you what we're wrong
he's coming to your yard when he's there
like what why do I need this facade bro
who am I shoving off to bro
nah there's oh my God speaking of
there's a movie I watched the other day
yeah
called it's a Ben Affleck movie Ben
Affleck and homegirl from knives out
um Anna diamas yes
she's a freak in this movie it's called
cold war or a deep War I can't remember
it might be called Deep Water have you
not spoken about this oh no no no no no
no no no it's deep water is the other
one because I made that mistake of
calling a deep war and then REM
corrected me saying it was Simon the
dark Waters you said dark Waters it
might be called Deep Water okay uh yeah
yeah show me the
um thingy
came out last year he's on netio it's on
what I watched it on Prime
um
people or psychological I've seen the
I've seen the post before I've never
watched it okay talk to me bro
it's not a good movie IMDb says 5.4 it's
not a good movie okay but but
Ben Affleck and uh Anna diamas they're
married She's A Freak he is like
semi-autistic doesn't have much emotion
okay the pre the premise is she's a G oh
a cheat she can't stop cheating oh and
he knows about the whole thing and she
shows it off
she'll invite the because where they
live in their in their neighborhood
there's always House parties like
um but not like childish Housewives like
I call like sophisticated like parties
okay in the neighborhood okay and she
will always invite her ting to the party
and then the neighborhood will have to
go to Ben Affleck like ah I'm not gonna
lie you need to Reign this girl in she's
floating this stuff and beneficial bro
he knows he's Adobe silly bro come on
man it's not that deep and then he
murders these guys
Ben does oh yeah
he's like yeah murders them oh he can't
handle he loves her and it's only 5.6 is
you'll if you watch the game you'll know
why it's Five Points okay the pacing and
the development is just not making sense
it makes sense but it's just like
it's kind of just like a flat timeline
okay whereas like cheat murder cheat
murder cheat murder okay end of movie oh
yeah driving okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a bit random okay the only thing I
can say is the move is random but good
Lord
this woman can cheat and she spins it
she cuckolds him like semi cuckolded
yeah and she's like don't play like
she'll she'll do little stuff oh my God
she'll do little stuff Prof this yeah is
a freak yeah yeah yeah yeah she'll be
banging other dudes yeah
she'll come and stumbling in the morning
and then Mama's like smash your windows
like brother where have you been
who have you been with oh my God and
she's like you want to know who I've
been with no you want to know if I did
stuff no and she'll be like here do you
wanna know if he made me nut do you want
to know how I make him numb no grabbing
his tool
Eternal conflict
[Music]
I'm so toxic I'm flipping between the
greatest sex of my life or arson again
yeah it's one of them when her and bear
back they bang bang
it's nuts it's nuts he can't get enough
of it the toxicity is in his blood you
can't get enough of it for your head and
I resonate when I'm watching it I'm like
I would want to kill this yeah yeah yeah
but every time
yeah it's nuts and then he tries to
he'll try to um he'll try to make her
jealous he'll do a little something a
little sight with one of one of the
local Yes and she'll hate it okay she'll
hate it and she'll be like oh do you
think uh home girl's paying and they'll
be like I don't know that's all right
he's like Pinker than me and he's like
nah never it's like
um
does she like do you think she sucks
better than me and he'll be like stop
and then he'll be driving she'll slop
him off that's your bite is talking
about stop it's like tell me do you
think she slaps better than me he's like
stop stop never she'll bite is tall
again
she'll stare at him
5.6 I'm watching this movie we'll be on
about what are we actually on about
watch it you'll be raging bro wow she's
banging in the movie oh she's banging
period anything period so every time he
murders a bread she'll find a new guy
the next day that's Madness to me she
loves young things
it's wild yeah that kind of sexual
tension is stuff I live for no it's wow
I couldn't get enough of it wow put it
on as a background yeah I I'm whole sick
it was 3 A.M before I finish that Jesus
Jesus Christ I can handle that I'd want
to murder myself
once you get that frustration not out
he's like oh my god you're an awesome
you're an actual [__]
that's hilarious it's crazy and she'll
do stuff in the yard when Ben's there no
she wouldn't yeah no she wouldn't if I'm
the point was the next man yeah she'll
invite next man over
to their yard for a dinner party and
when Ben's washing dishes
you'll hear her mowing in the other room
then we'll smash a dish this is actual
porn these are porn flicks
she cockles him against his will because
he can't leave he loves her too much
yeah that is toxic crazy about sex must
be incredible oh it's unbelievable bro
the stuff she says to him in the bed as
well knots
must be incredible
oh it's crazy Prof yeah the movie's wild
[__] movie but good Lord say less good
Lord
[Music]
they do that stuff from the jump of the
movie It's cheat kill cheat kill cheat
kill the whole flicks say less mad
welcome to the show guys welcome back
guys happy Monday as always
before we get into the normal
introduction guys
by popular demand by insistence by
consistent requests guys we have added
another show to the Log Cabin tour for
you guys so guys we're putting on a
second London show yep and it's going to
be Wednesday the 10th of May
Wednesday the 10th of May hack the
Empire again and hacking the Empire
again in London yep day before the
normal show guys it's gonna be gang so
tickets go on sale this Friday 10 a.m
yep 10 a.m and that's really much all
you need to know all you need to know oh
and we're doing some oh Bristol Bristol
man you've got extra tickets as well for
the same day yeah same event extra
tickets in Bristol yep yeah man that's
all we need to say 10 a.m I don't want
to hear anything else popular demand you
guys will screamed for extra dates extra
tickets this day and the other so once
this one goes I promise you we'll start
that's 20 20 if you're done yeah we're
not doing that Chris Brown I promise you
it's actually done yeah there's no more
bonus days none yeah done extra tickets
in Bristol extra sure in London and it's
over it's over yeah you have to wait
till next year yeah all right cool cool
um so that's that guys welcome back to
the show as always if you do love the
show if you want to be a cult baby for
real for real head on over to
patreon.com shits and gigs and for a
meezy three pound a month 10p a day you
can run the pita SMG and have a backlog
of three years of enjoyment three years
of episodes follow our journey every
other episode is
um a patreon episode we have one of the
best patreon uh channels communities
whatever you want to call it in the
country some would say the world others
say the Universe I don't keep track of
these things I'm just glad to be a part
of it so guys become a cult baby for
real for real head on over to patreon
today and um join our Discord join our
Zoom chats and just become part of the
community yeah episode every Thursday on
patreon
um if you watch us on YouTube please
help us with that mission one million
okay the super duper serious about
hitting mission one million yeah on
YouTube we've surpassed 600k the other
day and we're feeling sexy about it yes
it's it's numbers I've never even
dreamed yeah we're in a position we're
actively in a position now that I
actually never thought we would ever be
in yes man so it's gang so now we have
to just keep going we need to change
that to the gold ticket yeah Silver's
looking jarring yeah it's been
subscribe to the channel put the
notifications on and let's keep smashing
smashes smashing these numbers if you
are listening to us on Spotify or apple
podcast or Google podcasts or any of
your podcast apps please drop us a
follow leave us a nice review obviously
you know the drill five stars is always
preferable but whatever you say say it
with your chest okay guys right guys
let's take a very quick break from all
the who ha let's get some love over to
our favorite grooming company and that
is manscapes guys you already know this
is week on week was repetition to get
the message through your thick skulls
guys right so listen up real close if
you're looking to upgrade your hygiene
and grooming routine we recommend the
manscaped Platinum package 4.0 the king
of this package this is the lawnmower
4.0 and this trimmer offers a ceramic
blade and Advanced Skin safe technology
which reduces cuts and nicks to your
delicate Parts it also comes equipped
with a Thor
4000 K LED spotlight I can vouch for it
dark room doesn't matter yeah shave it
in the pitch black it doesn't matter
this thing will light your women's yeah
yeah it's luminous lumos
lumos oh my God all right so guys it's
something you never knew you needed and
it's a game changer okay this trim is
also the perfect size to travel with if
you are a bit busy traveler all you need
to do is head on over to manscaped.com
and use the exclusive code sng Sierra
November Golf and that's going to get
you 20 off and free shipping worldwide
guys do the right thing get it today
let's go back to the episode thank you
very much
before we go any further I have a
question for my main man if you have
talk to me I've got a question
so many people have asked me this like
this week
I asked you to ask me or ask you
people have asked me okay my opinion on
this okay say this
if I'm sorry for people probably people
have probably already asked you okay
obviously Chris Brown's been doing the
rounds the last series he's come to our
country and he's just yeah he just
spread his seed all over London yeah
pissed off yeah
turn the country apart
and if you were at your concert if
you're at a Chris Brown concert with
your girl
and she got grips on stage
regardless of the question though
but ask the question though what are you
doing oh what what um yeah okay cool
will you be there when she comes off
stage
so she's gone on stage yeah she's gone
on stage security grabbed her
no like shoot one of these oh no no if I
was about to call her a [__]
a hypothetical [__] if she puts her
arms out of here yeah she wants the
relationship to be over yeah she's
begging for the relationship to be over
are you Christ the Redeemer why your
arms out like that
you're begging for the relationship to
be done bro that's hilarious
thing just a swing Alex over the game
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that
signature class here
while he takes her down
I said I was still gonna be there when
she gets back
um it's mad because I probably will
still be there really but not because of
her because I want to join a show I'm
just vex I'm just absolutely living at
the moment cool what what would you say
to the man around you that with their
girl and then looking at you standing by
oh nobody that would make me leave that
alone would make me leave I'll be so
angry you're just waiting for it to come
back yeah because I can't even explain
myself everyone saw what happened yeah
every bear is holding his girl's waist
tight and saw that your girl was the one
that got lifted up this is the funniest
thing that changed the whole game for me
she was willing to go of course she was
of course she was and she's beaming up
there yeah yeah of course she is this is
her time and they just give her back to
you and she tries to wrap her up your
arms around her there I couldn't look
another man in the eye no I couldn't
because I know I could feel the eyes on
my neck I'll be able to I'd want to spit
on it yeah
I'll be that pissed on it bro that's the
thing because we can't have sex this
week
because I know where your head's at
facts I promise you I I promise you now
if she got this yeah I wouldn't be there
when she got back yeah
and so before she's even made it on the
stage I believe it yeah I can't bro I
can't that's
that's just certain no man should
experience no literally no man should
experience that
and I know the kind of man that have
experienced that the last few weeks I've
been like the kind of guys like ah oh
yeah yeah yeah
oh God
sister jokes oh yeah what can we do have
fun must be nice yeah no not me no I
promise you not me not me not me not me
not me not me it couldn't it couldn't
actually bang
um so yeah apology sort of Madam that
has happened to you because it just
couldn't be me bro
facts and then she has to go backstage
while he does a costume change unless he
does a costume change and then she finds
her way back to to you nah yeah because
she doesn't come back to offstage yeah
they take her back there right take her
where she needs to be taken
yeah she has to would have to find her
way home yeah I I promise you she's
hitchhiking yeah she would have to go
back with Chris or what yeah because you
you willingly did yeah yeah you
willingly do all that so it's impossible
yeah you you'll run tour with him now
because you have to dance on stage
you're under the influence yeah
you're under the [__] influence you
are is what you are yeah so enjoy it
yeah enjoy it I hope they've got yards
for you in there
wow oh wow and I promise you I'm dming
the [__] out of this ballad yeah but
everyone's going that she's going off on
stage she is I'm wow wow
that those cheeks clap your face I
forgot about that when she was doing
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah decide
yeah yeah
yeah yeah begging a response begging a
release you saw what happened on stage
yeah that was my girl I need to I need
some
help
also
thank God I'm not a Chris Brown because
I couldn't have people ever working for
me
um
because HR will be involved every
Wednesday
that's too much
tell a lie I think it's one of them ones
where
I feel like obviously this under the
original store for example that's been
going on since what January maybe or so
he even if they have collapsed I think
he would have been like he's over it
he's over it yeah and also yeah like he
sees her every morning with the Snapback
and like the lack of sleep
you know I mean yes and he's a bit it's
only sexy when she's on stage or when
she's getting ready
and he's getting on the tour bus and it
stinks a fast yeah you know what I mean
it's just stinks of people yeah yeah and
he's over and over it and he's seen her
do this routine a hundred times even
before the first day she's been
practicing yeah and she weren't wearing
those Arthur's chaps
so now it's all yeah I think the first
couple weeks he would have ran through
everyone they went on someone on his
team yeah yeah and he just cracks up
with the audience his business yeah it's
all business yeah you want this paper or
not wow yeah I remember when we were
younger
we went to go watch Trey Songz in his
armor went off I remember
yeah yeah yeah yeah he bought one Baddie
on stage I don't remember one mixed race
thing with curly hair I don't remember
good luck she was bad
I couldn't believe it and I was like
this day that is the life this is uh
yeah yeah that's what them are not up to
yeah and then I realized
we're the only guys in the room
it's me you and whoever went and tree
and his job and that's the only guys
here there was just gallons
screaming girl and us and I was like
what are we actually doing we were fans
bro yeah we were was it Trey five five
the album whatever I didn't remember do
you remember Ram it was it was uni times
well apparently dropper yeah it was a
penny drop album
anticipation it was anticipation memory
yeah yeah memory memory yes sir memory
yeah
come on bro that was a good album yeah
yeah eat as well
um but yeah what album I can't help but
wait do you remember before way before
he still had like the cornrows yeah he
was deep in the cornrows yeah he was
that was called trade day I think it was
God you man I got memory I think it was
called tray Day Jesus I think so
um yeah wow what time what a time what's
the time um game time game yes do your
game thing top five time I need to win
this time top five tops so last time Ram
technically won so yeah obviously you
guys have seen the disclaimer in last
week's video so technically it's 1-1 you
won the first game REM won the second
game Ellis is on zero but we go again
with top five all right calm
so this week guys I have ordered and
bought these guys mini whiteboards so
it's easy for them to write down their
answers you know cheating there's
nothing there's no influences there's no
literally no influences so it's easier
this way because these men have been
taking my answers and just yeah yeah
yeah taking my arms and spinning it so
what I'm gonna do is
um yeah well still everyone will still
write their top five and we'll just spin
it round one by one as opposed to
everyone saying their answers right cool
so this top five quiz is I want in 2022
oh god listen to me I already know it's
dodgy no it's not dodging I'm not gonna
get it
I want you guys
to give me the top five most downloaded
apps you think there were globally
in 2012 that's the whole of like top
five apps downloaded yeah
holy moly but what I would say is I
won't
I won't um I won't not give you a point
if it's not in order Okay cool so you
can give me any five in any order and
I'll give you a point but if you can
give me closest M to how many people
have downloaded it I'll give you an
extra point so it doesn't have to be in
any order again guys if you want to play
at home if you can name me the top five
most downloaded apps globally of 2022 as
well as
the closest million how do I like this
one you done yeah I'm done
I got like
he would he's competing now he's
competing now how many guys
I've got five now gang Ram I got five
you got the numerical figure as well are
we skipping I get I've done two
numericals and I gave up I'm giving [__]
I'll give you one numerical bro and give
a damn say less
all right it's a stupid game man
[Laughter]
so Jimmy you ready
you're good to go you're locked in I'm
locked in cool everyone locked down are
you locked in yeah unless you're locked
in yeah cool Hey listen let's start with
you give me your top five cool so not in
order not in order
Tinder Instagram YouTube Spotify
and I actually think because of the like
new animes Crunchyroll
cool
um Tinder I should have done a dating
app
yeah
I should have done YouTube I didn't do
YouTube if I should have done YouTube
Bro didn't even cross my mind this is
such an ill Vex about that insta
Discord WhatsApp Twitter only fans
only fans isn't a nap
to be fair yeah you just yeah you're
right you're right it's not enough
you're right wow that's all www
[Laughter]
um Jimmy I did Tick Tock Disney plus
insta Twitter Spotify
say the five again Tick Tock Disney plus
Instagram Twitter Spotify cool
number 10 I'm gonna do ten to six before
I give you the top five God all right
just for that anticipation whatever
number ten was Spotify okay
number nine never even heard of it
stumble guys
do not know what that is 254 million
people downloaded it stumble guys is it
a game I have no idea brother sounds
like a game Facebook number eight 298
mil oh actually give me
um oh no we'll do that after I just
actually
number seven Subway Surface do you
remember that game that was probably
like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Subway
Surface 304 Milli number six telegram
310 million what's that [__] nose
all right number five
anyone get Snapchat really anyone get
Snapchat
330 M's wow okay number four which no
one got cap cut
oh that's that yeah what people are
using for the that's number one on the
um photography on if you click if you go
on Instagram you see it's got like child
I think it's like number three oh the
fact that they put the cap cutting at
the end of every video I mean I promise
you I've never done it I know that 357
Milli number three
WhatsApp oh my God what's up days you
too you get what's up oh I didn't get it
no you got WhatsApp okay what's up ciao
did you put a number or no
I've actually written WhatsApp third
no Millie number no gang that I meant
Million numbers
um no but I would guess
um yeah happy guess did you get it right
have a guess
I'll give you the point if you're
closest to 10 million I'll give you a
point
um
say
400 and
32 mil wow you get a point
it's 424 million well played this is
[__] well played red it's not fair
well played you influenced him he knows
what the number before that was
doesn't matter bro of course it matters
wait I've got obviously choose a number
higher than that number but it doesn't
it could be any number bro it can't be
any number
higher than that number there are a bag
of numbers after 300 million bro yeah
all right bro whatever giving us two
points and let's guess I have given him
his two points it's my game
number two Instagram did anyone have
Instagram yeah you all had Instagram
cool
um closest Milling
um well you can't guess now can you
because you don't need the number before
yeah I won't take the point then really
yeah [__] this game you need it
I don't need anything I promise you now
I don't need this [__] game
so I swear down say your Millions bro
500 million 500 mil cool I'll write
yours down here five you all wrote um
Instagram right yep what was your give
me your give me your Millie off the Huff
um
500 and
183. give me your Milly
620.
the answer is
548 million
closest person
is rep but then again I said in 10
minutes so you don't get the point yeah
you know what I mean closer than James
and number one he thinks I'll carry on
playing I won't ever play this again and
I will snap both your mic
I'll Dash all the my Expo wow wow
competitive mom facts this is stupid not
number one snap all the mics wait what
What's
um what's the one you haven't said
the one I haven't said oh no so that's
fine ignore me ignore me last but not
least number the number one most
downloaded app of 2022
Tick Tock that was my number one Tick
Tock what did you write I didn't even
write tick tock
uh Tinder oh um Milly give me a Millie
uh I would actually say this one's way
high I would say this one's like 750 mil
672. fair enough
so
that's that that concludes today's top
five
Ellis you got a resounding one point
James you got resounding two points and
the winner with three points Israel come
on I won't play next week you will uh
that so that's three to REM one to Jimmy
nil to Ellis in total how is it three to
M two to M two two games two games oh
yeah yeah because there's one one before
sorry yeah yeah so two one zero well
play guys we go in again next week and
what we got next One Last of Us oh Last
of Us episode six episode episode six so
after like like that thrilling have you
where are you up to remember are you up
to date or no
but I still need to watch at five don't
even yeah you're up today right today
um so we we always spoil this for him
because he's never up to date and he
doesn't want to
um
Monday says Thursday yeah he just
doesn't want you yeah he's had time he
doesn't want to yeah yeah
I know we um
yeah the episode was pretty chilled glad
he found his brother but then it was
obviously a bit of a Twist about him
Jonah wanted to stay and he has to go
and then obviously Ellie was like oh I
don't want to go as well I want to go as
well with you and then the little little
shank little thing at the end you're not
shanking me with a broken baseball bat
tell you that for free yeah yeah yeah
yeah that I'm just trying to that
I was trying to figure out how did that
even actually happen because he tried to
swing for man and he missed and
obviously it broke but I didn't see him
yeah
I thought the thing just left his hand
yeah yeah I didn't see none of that and
then Joel had him up yeah and snapped
his neck fam like a man he did snap his
neck like a grown ass man one thing I've
realized in this episode is that like
the same way I'm not entertaining these
games when you men are having fun
is the same way Joel's not entertaining
people having news when history got
taken
it was ah that was tough he doesn't want
to [__] hear it yeah especially when
Ellie was coming up to him like I heard
about what's her name Sarah Sarah Sandra
or something like Sarah Sarah I heard
about Sarah he's like don't you dare
mention fam don't talk about her talk
about her he's like you don't know loss
because you're like big man I grew up in
this idea no loss everyone I've known is
either dead or left that's why I'm going
cross-country with you because I know
because if I had someone else they would
take me yeah facts bro that I'm I'm
starting to not even starting it's been
from the jump but I love the
relationship they have
but it's also one of those ones where
it's like how much further can they go
because
obviously we don't know what's going to
happen in terms of Ellie and uh Herbie
and immune potentially and but yeah it's
just a weird dynamic because obviously
we don't know it was a climatic
ending on this one where you got you got
a little Shanks in his abdomen but it's
also one of those ones where
are we are we gonna see a lot more out
of the show do you think yeah I think so
I think so how many episodes of the
season does anyone know like I was nine
nine so three months ago yeah we're
gonna see some staff
because this is like it's following the
game and it's like every game has a
massive climate ending yeah so it's
gonna have to build to some stuff
they're gonna go to Salt Lake City or
whatever they need to go to link these
man and like along the way they're
probably gonna have to face an army of
massive flipping infected I don't know
bro yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to
yeah we'll see we'll see it's it's great
don't get me wrong it's it's I'm not I'm
not not enjoyed I'm enjoying every every
episode but it's just one of those ones
where
because episode one and two arms three a
bit more relaxed but like touch the
heart four you started to see that Peak
again and then five again arms with the
you've not seen it but when you watch it
bro yeah you'll jump out the chair and
the six was a bit more relaxed
um but we'll see we'll see I feel like
six is bringing
um I don't want to use disappointment's
a heavy word yeah but because something
like him getting stabbed is such a big
deal yeah but it wasn't given to us it
wasn't delivered as a big deal thing
that is given a bit like it makes you
feel like oh this maybe the series just
slowing down a bit because like is he
gonna die we can't be bothered to watch
if he dies we really don't know if you
don't yeah I've never play the game so I
don't even know the storyline exactly
and I'll be damned if I'm following
Eddie and someone else by yourself yeah
we do like Joel is he'll die yeah for
starters yeah and yeah the way it was
delivered was a bit like it wasn't like
oh my God yeah yeah it's just like all
right it's a surprise team yeah yeah so
we're kind of just left in a bit of a
run the next episode now I need it I
need it now to be fair he's obviously
he's obviously not gonna die because the
people that actually shanked him up were
nobody's yeah that's another thing he
got shanked by some random Raider yeah
that's dead yeah so he's obviously not
gonna die but yeah he's he's in he's in
bits yeah it it leaves a lot for the
next episode because I need to know what
Ellie's gonna do she needs to figure
something out she needs to figure
because he's Lee's literally bleeding
out yeah and they're in the middle of
nowhere literally yeah maybe he's I'm
assuming maybe I don't want to assume
maybe his brother runs through does
science someone's gonna come and save
the day yeah oh yeah because she told he
told her brother his brother to not tell
his missus about Ellie's situation he's
obviously gonna run his mouth he's a
waste man he's got you on Route so when
they she was spilling means about like
um we don't let people use the radio and
then and he looked at his brother this
thing I came all the way here for you
because you weren't answering the radio
and now you were just knocking [__]
up when I'm suffering thinking my
brother's dead yeah that's that's
yeah and I'm having to bribe the radio
guy in the qz because I don't know if
you're alive or dead yes Madness it's
absolutely and the whole reason I'm
stuck with Ellie is because I was
looking for a car battery so I can come
and see you yeah even if you were alive
or not yeah yes
and now I've been stabbed
[Music]
you're gonna be a what he was in this
economy it was livid
bro yeah you're doing up happy lives I'm
gray as hell just deluded Behind These
Walls he's deluded I promise you if you
had because I feel like you're the kind
of person would do that to me
do explain yourself explain yourself
thoroughly butterfly thoroughly I feel
like because
you're you love everyone around you but
when it push comes to self you're about
Numero Uno
so you won't acknowledge what you're
doing to me when you move in with some
[__]
in this Utopia you're thinking Life's
good now you don't know what's going on
with me in Chicago Jeremy oh so you're
coming try and find me yeah yeah you're
asking a radio with it yeah you're Joel
yeah yeah when you're the brother yeah
and yeah I'm Joe you're the brother and
I'm thinking he hasn't answered the the
radio in weeks yeah what's going on I
think he's dead and when
when I find you yeah you'll be like and
I'll be like big man where I can travel
across country to infected through like
Raiders through this revolution Place
yeah I've seen people kill their little
brothers I've seen people kill
themselves I've had to kill people and
he's had to kill people this is also we
could come and see you you know you'll
be like what do you want me to say am I
supposed to just stay in the trenches
this bridge offered me a better life why
are you boiling so I mean
and his boss here everyone's happy why
aren't you happy for me and I lost my
daughter as well yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you say James I'm not being rude but
just because your livestock doesn't mean
I couldn't save it you wouldn't make it
out I want to say that you know you know
how to say that that's not something I
would ever say
I'm not staying out in a cold answering
radios to keep you give you peace of
mind is it no see the thing is I would
it's tough because obviously the reason
why he didn't answer the radios because
they didn't want obviously online people
to come and find where they're at yeah
yeah I would also try and find a way to
sneakily use the Raider once in a while
to hollow you as opposed to every time
you holler at me I'm replying yeah you
know what I mean I hate that yeah one
message like fam
FY I'm fine don't contact me again yeah
some but don't make you want to contact
me more yeah
you back immediately you build me
straight away you'll be dialing whatever
dial you need to dial to get that
connection through fam fact I'll play
whatever it is music needs to be played
this is an emergency what do you mean
don't Bell me again
you think the whole thing is a facade oh
you're you're hostage yeah yeah facts
you're coming in yeah you're coming in
yeah yeah yeah calm all right yeah but I
hope he's gonna it's gonna get
interesting moving forward yeah I'm
really really enjoying the relationship
between Joel and Elias yes
it's crazy because obviously as much as
he knows that's not his daughter
he needs that in his life
and it's so big it needs that bond in
his life because he's broken his side oh
he's a br he's still wearing the broken
watch brother
from episode one I didn't even notice
that I'm telling you I wouldn't survive
if my daughter got killed like that
especially like that yeah I wouldn't
survive fuhad
it's um it's it's actually crazy it's
been 20 years and he's still going
through this there's no because he's had
no what's the word I'm looking for he's
not grieved he's not a chance to bro and
there's no one to vent to yeah
we never saw his misses
we never saw his misses she's been gone
yeah yeah and then the next lump of his
life she was swollen up next man's liver
it's long I found the way you started
that sentence I was thinking pardon she
was swallowing up next man's what
what's her name just no test test test
test move she's got moved too yeah yeah
yeah so it's like what more do I have
foreign
to tell your brother that the love of
your life is dead
that's pain can't be bothered yeah Joel
is going through I promise you I'll jump
I will jump into a pile of infected
swallow me whole pause
swallow me up because I don't want to
live like this this is not living yeah
it's to be fair it's not living but I'm
not jumping into it I'm not gonna lie to
anyone here bro I'm not doing it I'm
gonna try and see if tomorrow I can live
again I'm gonna try and see if there's a
little antidote um yeah also I'm moving
to Florida Sign because these men are
dealing with all of this in the cold
it's been cold since episode one true
I'm tired of it Global warm is a Maza
it's a mother it's been cold in every
episode and I'm not dealing with this
anymore yeah that's the thing that will
send me yeah the call the call I would
have died a time ago 20 years I would
have died time ago yeah yeah as soon as
also when they're putting dead bodies on
fire and this is just daily life
all along bro kids old people
everything's just going on the fire
because they got a little they got
nibbled yeah nah yeah I'm telling you
I'm jumping off satin and that's crazy
mum yeah very very good Jesus you've got
another show to recommend have I just oh
wow full swing really full [__] swing
you know what's funny bro is I saw that
advertising I was like gang they're
coming after me again I'm watching it
and then I'll spoke to Lewis who's balls
deep in golf and he was like I was like
oh yeah we'll talk about Golf and he was
like I said oh yeah they got that full
swing thing because I'm not gonna lie I
put it on the background it seemed
boring and I was like okay it's not
boring I'll say that for [__] free I
watched apart from episode one because I
watched the night before I watched two
till I think eight or nine in one day
wow brother it's a show is it on par
with drive to survive
use
no but I would say it's better than
Breaking Point say less personally it's
better than Breaking I'm gonna watch it
today and
that was because remember I said I had
something to say in patreon I'll say it
here mandem we need uh Jay said this
before we need to start golf yeah I
think that could be our team our new
song we need guys comments DM me
whatever where is a good none of us play
golf first and foremost have you ever
played golf I've played Top Golf and The
Ting always yeah that's right yeah I
play Top Golf as well and I'm terrible I
can Pelt it yeah it swings right I'm
terrible
send us a location where we can play
golf and actually learn as amateurs
we're not trying to do up Tiger Woods
none of that it doesn't have to be like
deals yeah old white exactly it doesn't
have to be in London because there's not
much green around here we're talking
East Midlands yeah sort us out we'll do
it but bro full swing is a show these
men really really really know how to do
a sports documentary I'm not even
Captain brother I I cannot I had the
same like wow factor when I first
watched um drive to survive oh because
obviously
same premise I never give a [__] about
F1 before I watched Dragon survived yeah
yeah I don't give a [__] about golf yeah
no one does balls deep James you're
gonna be in watching the Masters in that
the thing is right
I don't know if I'm going to be watching
but as I was watching the show I'm
thinking I need to watch PGA Tour now
because I need to get these behind the
scenes Banton yeah and I saw from what
intrigued me I didn't recognize a single
[__] face in the trailer fax I didn't
know who anyone was back so I was like
all right this is what I want to watch
some of the Yards these men live in
James
see now I'm sold oh my goodness start
with that next time I love money now I'm
sold episode four is probably the
peakiest episode of any sports document
I've ever seen it's called imposter
syndrome you wouldn't love it oh I know
you would love it okay I would say today
I'm watching it too you would love it
stop roller coaster of emotions
[__] it's a good shot okay okay I don't
know what I don't know what Lewis was
saying to you yeah he's a liar I've
never taken his word for anything media
related before so I'm not gonna need you
related I'm not gonna start now it's a
TV show
s like I'm jumping on and it's arriving
just in time for driver's survive season
five yeah I can't wait yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah because I didn't really watch
the season properly and I know George
Russell has been yeah balls deep he's
been [__] these men on the track he's
getting a recognition
where was he before Williams Williams
trash they wouldn't even be able to
point the seats
in Mercedes he was having me let's go
let's go let's go let's go bro full
swing yeah
I just full swung my neck with that yeah
it's um guys full swing watch it if you
guys like any form of sporting
documentary I promise you I I promise
you you said that you had a show
recommendation I couldn't I couldn't
fathom what you could be yeah yeah
because we want some similar cells yeah
yeah but yeah full swing say less I
started watching half of
um last night I watched half of All
Quiet on the Western Front
the world war one movie yeah I was
thinking that is that Prime no uh
Netflix no yeah I've seen it but
nominated from Oscar I'm pretty sure
just now okay um just now uh
um yeah we wouldn't make it
wouldn't make it two days into World War
One
and the way they um
lion gas man up to get to get involved
and it's come from Germany's side I also
need to do research about how World War
One started by the way I know all about
these Hitler things in World War II yeah
I don't even know why one of World War
One yeah yeah yeah yeah but these men
were just doing up at Madness elsewhere
yeah and um
in school they were recruiting people in
school
and they had to get their parents to
sign fam it follows the main character
and they had to get uh your parents had
to sign like a school trip that your
parents had to sign a little leaflet to
say you could sign up for the Army one
Don's parents were like you're not going
in there big man I'm not signing [__] he
got his boy to forge his signature he
ain't seen his parents since that
morning
since the morning this person said I'm
not signing that he went to school
forced the signature then got recruited
that afternoon and then got shipped
straight to Paris to fight in the
trenches big man he hasn't seen his
parents since that that day
yeah I would have made kid products what
instigated World War one I don't know
I don't know and the comments are going
to blow up because that's basic history
yeah but I don't give a f i [__] about
basic history clearly that's what I'm
asking the question bro
trench warfare is no game oh I I know
well I don't know but I can imagine fam
the first thing these men did when they
got there it was pissing down with rain
shock muddy water was up to their knees
no they had to use their helmets to get
the stuff out the water out
to stop the trench foot to get like is
like dry booster yeah dry booster
happiness that's all they care about dry
boots is what makes you happy yeah so
they would use their helmets to like dig
out of water they're not getting
anything out
they're just doing it
oh my fam it's long the whole thing is
long they're starving they're eating
potatoes every day all day every day
it's the most Buzz I'm only halfway
through it's the most Buzz thing I've
seen
I wouldn't make it wow and one brother
in there doesn't when I say they in
capture their fear
they encapsulate fear fans there's one
scene in there with it in this bunker
yeah and um the French are bobbing them
yeah and they're in The Ting shake it
yeah one brother loses it one brother
loses it okay and he's only like 16 or
whatever oh no he wants to get me out he
says Get me the [__] out he tries to get
up the captain dashes him back down yeah
he starts smacking his head against the
wall oh my goodness he can't take it
anymore oh my goodness he's like brother
I can't be here that's why sign up fine
why sign up these men were gassing them
like as an anime their head teacher was
gassing them in school like it's an
anime
what promises and stuff yeah they're
doing up like Valhalla type chat oh my
God perfect that's all I need is another
perfect reference the kids are laughing
at us oh wow and it's like they're basic
gas I'm like you men are gonna do a
Madness in Paris you're gonna they're
basically just saying you're gonna dump
him out and [__] that's what's going on
over there you're gonna dump him man
clap cheeks and come back Heroes
I need 16 year old brothers are like
holy [__] I've never heard of stuff
these are real men yeah they're saying
the German armies for men are you a man
or not I know these men are like gang
wow and then what they were doing bro is
it English by the way no it's fully in
German oh subtitles what they were doing
bro is they would send man in all these
men would get murked they would take the
German man all these German men would
get murked because this is like man to
man before World War because World War
II is when they started introducing like
tax and all that here we're talking
about gun on gun somebody's like running
yeah coming out the trench running
shooting I'm saying
40 50 60 000 people were dying a week
in from one side let alone from the
other side yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
were just they would get killed they
would take their uniform off they would
bury these man or burn them and they
would send all the uniforms
to back to Germany where they'll get
washed they would sew up the bullet
holes and give it to the next one no
give it to the next man and then when
homeboy picked up his uniform or gassed
he had next man's name in it and he was
like oh you've given me next man's
uniform I need mine and he was like oh
no no no sometimes they give we give
them out they're a bit small so they
give them back that's why he's got his
name in it he rips his name I was like
bro this is for you and he's like say
let's say less someone died in that last
week
it's crazy brother wow crazy we wouldn't
make it wow yeah war is nuts the idea of
war is not it's not World War
yeah I've got no business in Paris let
the man do what they're doing
it's crazy thought of war is Bonkers to
me yeah you couldn't send me you can
never send me yeah yeah you couldn't
send me and then the reason homeboy
wanted to go so bad because he just
didn't want to look a [__] yeah because
all demanding my God yeah it's peer
pressure
wow all the man them are going if you're
not going your [__] oh man if the man
don't do it I'll do it that's the flex
they were on facts and I know back then
I would have done it as well
I can't stay at home I'm the only bear
going to school every day nah it was a
ball I'll be a life instead yeah yeah
yeah don't be dashing apples that man
why aren't you at War Impossible it's
just me and all the girls
it's just me and all the girls yeah and
I'm not smart enough to do that that's
the better situation yeah yeah
in the trenches facts fighting I'm here
with all the things and I'm not clapping
these men are over there clapping and
fighting that's what I'm thinking
they're doing it up and I'm sitting in
telegraphs I'm not even hearing anything
back
[Laughter]
western front so let's I'll watch it
this week yeah gang okay you've got a
threat to finish this off here uh yeah
[__] I forgot about that we've
actually done this Fred before but
someone reinstigated on um Twitter and
bag a man without me saying I have to do
I have to do after oh really yeah okay
gang so the question is how did you find
out you were getting cheated on oh yeah
yeah I remember we did this before and
obviously the response is braze her
friends started pursuing me because they
knew I wasn't the one
deep that James
her friends started pursuing me because
they knew I wasn't the one
wow
that's insanity
everyone knows but me that's insanity
but why the friends
yeah that's also mad I will make me
think what's going on they must think
you also they must think you're a man
they might think you're right yeah yeah
yeah she's crazy yeah that's what
they're thinking I need that give me
that it's mental turn me on but my
heartbreak wouldn't be yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
supersede the boner yeah
oh
took her to my friend's place and the
dog didn't bark at her
she's familiar she's familiar showed her
his belly turnover showed her his belly
so she can play WoW no no no no no no no
no no no
you ever opened your fridge and realized
someone had a sip of your drink and then
put it back and you didn't realize
this is not about food
peak man took a bite of my girl and just
gave her back to me and you think I
wouldn't realize
that's not a way I want to find out yeah
I'm not a way I want to find out I won't
know where to direct my anger
not cheated on but I found out I was
exciting when I was chilling with the
dude I had been [__] with and kept
saying my girl this my girl that and I
was thinking oh he's talking about me I
asked him oh am I like your girl then
and he said nah you're my girl are
nothing alike
no no no no no no
no no
thing I like and don't even attempt to
insinuate that you're anywhere near my
that's bravado bam your skin and that's
it
I'm talking about my wife sharp and
listen respected
why are you buying in I'm talking about
the love of my life wow your flesh
flesh can't chat like that you shouldn't
talk like that
[__]
now you are my girl are nothing alive
nah she's she's genuinely believed he's
talking about her yeah wow she if she
was on the bridge she would have jumped
because oh wow
I don't need this WOW nah you're my girl
or nothing alike that's crazy talk
people say the craziest thing yeah I
don't know where The Bravery comes from
because I would expect to get stabbed
yeah right something used to happen to
me yeah cause I'm looking at my shoulder
for at least a week because that's the
craziest thing I've ever said yeah
she left her IG
[Laughter]
I just did what you said that's so funny
I'd have to be wrong oh God so how did
you find out you were getting cheated on
[Laughter]
[__] she left her IG logged in on my
phone and I found a DM saying I can't
believe you fit my whole dick in your
mouth
we're doing this across IG you didn't
even have to curse you get his number
before you swallowing pipe
I can't believe you fit the whole thing
in your mouth I couldn't read that
brother
said I couldn't read that my you see how
man lost his grip on physical 100. I
would lose my grip on the phone I would
lose my grip on reality
foreign
because I wouldn't be able to believe
that this is happening to me facts how
is why is this happening to me bro I
would never click on an Xbox profile so
fast in my life who is he I would assume
the pinch and squeeze third screenshots
soon
I need to see that profile pic fax wow
wow no no no no no I actually can't
handle that my hands will shake
bloodshot eyes blood short eyes bro
that's a level of heartbreak I can't
fathom ah
[__] started to wear lotion you've been
actually the whole relationship that you
want to be dipped and butted out of
nowhere I ain't stupid I know things I'm
super attentive
wow oh growing up mid relationship stuff
happening that's unfair she's seeing
someone at work that she fancies why
does he deserve this and I don't that's
what I'll be thinking you're lazy you're
lazy you do nothing for me and you know
me as well oh because you're both
accustomed to this lifestyle you just
this is this is my life now
she's found someone yeah the fact that
you would you the fact that you were
fine with me being ashy means you're not
for me
fair you're not full you were just
comfortable with me looking like this
there yeah he won't tolerate it for a
second that's what I like that's what I
need that turns me on here
[Laughter]
he demands the best version of yeah yeah
and he's gonna get it oh isn't he Justin
isn't he just
hilarious wow
she posted snaps in his bedroom on her
finsta but her and I have mutual friends
so they told me about it I confronted
him and he said why are you asking me
things you already know about
wow
some people are so brave in this world
bro yeah there needs to be I don't know
what scenario I'm in once I have zero
fear of repercussion yeah
that's a level of bravado wow wow wow
wow why are you asking irrelevant
questions yes I cheated you clocked out
yeah you knew why are you here yeah why
are you asking me remedials yeah yeah
[__] off yeah literally asking me stupid
rhetoricals you know the answer to and
you think I'm gonna waste my breath
answering you get out if you're going
[__] well sit down if you're saying bags
it's one or the other I don't want to
hear it I don't want to hear it
wow
wow indeed bro
he moaned my best friend's name
mid-strokes after he went out drinking I
unlocked his phone and typed her number
in and found out that they had a stared
been in a stable relationship
they had been in a stable relationship
oh stretches
well
he brought the [__] to my house took me
to our bedroom and told me to pretend
that we just lived together
he brought the [__] to my house talk me
to our bedroom and told me to pretend
that we were just living together
I don't even know it's impossible what
was coming through his head to ask to
say that to her to your misses babes by
the way by the way there's a thing
coming over you see the thing I just
bought through do you think the thing
downstairs that's my take yeah yeah what
needs to happen right now is you need to
just say she's gonna be chatting she's
gonna be chatting just say we just live
together you're not my girl we just live
together we just live together
she's the one safe safe one downstairs
is the one I owe you I owe you
I owe you you're a real one you know
what you're actually a real one you
deserve you you're gonna get the world
not for me but you're in the world
you're gonna get the wall from someone
and this is just a start this is just a
start don't never doubt yourself
this is self self-help never ever
anyone tell you you ain't 100 because
you are you are you are a hundred
because if you can do this to me you can
do this right one and this is why this
is why I [__] with you wow this is how
you made it this far
listen to me James just say we live
together this this can't have happened
it couldn't there's no woman on planet
Earth there isn't one that would agree
to that literally isn't one woman
he must have threatened over violence
100 because it's just no other 100 bro
he's done it he's dumped the whole thing
down wow there's no way any woman on
earth will agree to that wow on Earth
brother
on Earth it's impossible it's crazy it's
actually impossible so if you had
mentioned that like you guys broke up
but you're still living together and
she's supposed to sit there and relax
yeah
she's stabbing more people than one yeah
like she's stabbing people
James facts my girl could never bring a
next man into my home
and make me lie to him and say oh we
just listen together that's not my love
we just stay here
I don't know
I actually don't know how I'd reacts I
would get a prostitute in that building
in the next five minutes and I'll be
doing the most in there and then I'll
burn us all inside it's arson for sure
yeah arson for sure but I don't I need
to do sign ups because I don't
understand why you thought this was
acceptable no yeah because she came in
it's not like she left my man in the car
be like baby
the man's downstairs waiting waiting for
us
ah brother yeah yeah that's my that's
that's the end of the episode that's mad
that's crazy that's the craziest ending
to any episode we've done that's crazy
bro all right guys well thank you so
much as always if you want to catch us
on Thursday yeah hit us up on
patreon.com shits and gigs
um and as always guys love love
[Music]
thank you